Let's start by filling out what was given.
We know the initial x velocity is just this velocity--50 m/s.
The x acceleration is 0, as it almost always is, and the y acceleration is 10.
Δy is this height--100 m--and the initial y velocity is 0,
because this is being shot exactly horizontally--no component of this velocity is vertical.
We can plug these variables into this equation to get a value for t.
When we do this algebra, we get a time of 4.47 s.
Remember, both of these times are identical.
I can use these three values to find the final y velocity.
It gives me a value of 44.7 m/s.
And what about the x?
Well, if I know the initial x velocity is 50 m/s,
I know that velocity never changes.
The acceleration is 0 in the x direction. This means the final x velocity is 50 m/s.
To calculate the distance it travels in the x direction--that's this distance here--
I can use this equation. Of course, this term goes to 0, since the x acceleration is 0.
When I solve this, I find Δx is equal to 224 m.
Well, if you got this on your first try, I am very impressed.
If you didn't, hey, go back and try it again.
If you're still confused after a few tries, go to the forums.
I'll be there. So will Jonathan, the assistant instructor and all of your classmates,
and we're all happy to help.